what's going on
man what's up not much um some people
had called and they said that they saw
you walk and they were just concerned
that you were going to get his
everything all right yeah I was supposed
to be waiting for my wife to come pick
me up and I have freaking asth and I
can't breathe and she lives down by that
store so I had to walk I'll be out with
that mail just north of 9562 956 at the
end at the
store she lives down there uh what's
your wife's name uh Jesse Stevens okay
you guys are married no we're we're in G
okay um and she's supposed to be coming
to pick you up she said that I've been
calling our car a 30 times she was
answer so I was I was just I know where
she lives um do you want me to give you
a ride or do you need a squad if you're
have like do if you want just put your
butt right here that way you can sit
down and kind of tripod a little bit and
catch your
breath where are you coming from
oh I'm sorry you're good where are you
coming
from me and her got into an argument
okay and no one hit each other or
nothing like that we just got we just
got into an
argument and I took off walking down
here and Suess you going to come and get
me do you want me to call you a squad to
come check you
out I just I want herur be here I'll
tell you what how about I call one they
can come check you out if you don't want
to go to the hospital you don't have to
but at least they can check your vitals
make sure you're good to go if they need
to give you a breathing treatment or
something like that um they can maybe
take you to the hospital or they can
give you a breathing
treatment do you mind I'll do that but
do you mind do you have an ID with you
so I can just tell my dispatchers who
I'm talking to and I'll get one started
this way I don't I don't need no
ambulance I'm fine are you sure like I'm
fine she has myhers I can breathe but
it's it's hot 26 signal
11 I don't know why I kep trying to tell
her to bring her ass here and she don't
want to freaking
listen Tom Robert 038 747 Tom Robert 038
747 I'm going put this back in here for
you I'm a pro and
everything what's the parole
for uh just uh I I did some time cuz I
had a registration thing and I messed up
for so many years offender reg they sent
me the prison and I got out and I'm only
got four month three months left and I'm
finished with everything okay who's your
PO uh it's some new guy I I don't yeah
in B I don't have to go check in or
nothing like that go ahead so is it like
diversion then or something similar or
you on full parole no I'm on parole I
just I don't have to drug test I don't
have to check in I just have have to
check in with the sheriff and he knows
where I'm at he knows I live out
there I gave him my number too he knows
my phone number I don't know why he's
not answering
okay do you mind if give me a ride there
that's fine um before we get in do you
mind if I just pat you down make sure
you don't have anything um this I have
um I I'm not suicided or nothing but I
do there's pocket knives in there okay
they're little little tiny ones okay
that's fine just put your hands there
I'll pat you down real quick nothing
that's going to poke me stick me or blow
me up or anything right I think I just
got my chain on my rings and another
phone just W
wallet put this back in
here and I just started my new job where
you working this new place it's called
something I don't know it's in it's in
uh real quick it's in uh you're good
kitten it's this plastic place called K
uh there in I yeah uh not plastic pack
no it's not plastic pack or something
else I don't know what it's called but
we do country we do work out there and
her dad he has me cutting stuff cutting
trees cutting limbs so that's why I have
those I work for him in his backyard
okay but I'm not I a do
anything I'll have you sit in the back I
got a bunch of shit up here in the front
seat but
you sure you don't want to Squad I'm
sure
okay
oh hey how are
you okay we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this body cam
video I mean I think it's pretty clear
from the body cams that we covered that
it's not always safe out there when
you're hurt it can be confusing it can
be scary you don't really know where to
turn well Morgan and Morgan is actually
the largest injury law firm in America
and in a time when you already have so
much to think about they're going to
make it super easy for you they have
completely modernized the process
because you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents you talk
to your whole legal Team all on your
phone that's it an attorney is going to
review your case in just eight clicks
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your
phone you all
right milk all over me
are you all right yeah um so I have
Marcel in my car somebody called in they
were afraid he was walking down 6:38
they were afraid he was going to get hit
yeah I couldn't get this thing to start
I was trying to come and get him
okay why couldn't you get it to start I
don't know it's a piece of
crap is he allowed to be here yeah okay
I can't breathe you're good
man
are you okay I offered to get him a
squad he said he thinks he's having an
asthma attack oh do you need
the he's in healer Marcel why don't you
let me call
healer
here
here come here
it's okay breae
bre I am I'm taking you this thing is
pie piece of
crap I bit my
tongue Jesse have you had anything to
drink today no you've been doing any
drugs or anything like that no I can
tell you she hasn't we just got into AR
okay cuz ever since you stepped out of
the car you've been stumbling you're
you're your words so oh no I'm not on
anything no no do me favor look
up
okay oh things a piece of crap my what's
wrong with the TRV my tongue I bit it C
you why you answer me CU going vibrate I
was trying to get this to start mom the
keys were supposed to be brought back to
uh the CRV but my dad never showed up I
told him that and I told him that you
can't
okay if you
would my God start me in a
second I better really bad so what's
going to happen well do you need me to
get a squat for you cuz I'm a little
concerned for your health just give me
myher I did I gave it to you I'll stay
with my
inhaler I have to look I have to look in
here and double check that the keys are
not okay well can you give me can I call
my mom give me your phone
please
okay so damn
hot I found the keys all
right so I'll tell you
what
do me a favor yeah I'm going to offer
you to do some field sobriety tests okay
okay do you want to participate in them
sure
okay cuz right now I I I'm not too sure
you should be driving okay okay just
based on what I'm seeing sir if you want
to stand off to the side and watch
that's fine if you want to just go
inside or or do
whatever right here honey here man
please have it you drop this I'm sorry
you're
good it's 268 man
I uh no it's not here where's the
where's the house just keep them on
there it's fine just give me
everything
Jesse what I want you to do this is this
is a pretty flat level area of your
driveway the gravel is nice and packed y
so what I want you to do step back here
for me and then face
me right here just right here that's
fine right here now just face me with
your toes together heels and Toes
touching hands down to your sides okay
you can put the keys in your pocket
that's
fine
so what I'm going to do first is check
your eyes Okay and then after that we'll
have you I'll have you do a couple other
things I'm going to have you just turn
around that way the sun's not in your
eyes go ahead and turn around for me all
right can you see the tip of my finger
okay yep all right just follow it with
your eyes and your eyes only okay
okay go ahead and blink if you need
to all right we're going to do that
again
okay
I'm sorry about all this sir you're all
right sorry
Jessie you're
fine
all right we're going to go nice and
slow now
okay
I'm okay I'll be on a 77 all right now
we're going to go up
okay
okay are you normally able to cross your
eyes cross my eyes yeah like can you
cross your eyes I mean I guess okay I'm
going to do a couple of circles with my
finger like this and then I'm going to
come in towards your nose I'm not going
to touch your nose but just try and
follow my finger with both to your eyes
Okay my eyes supposed to cross uh that
kind of depends on the person
individually some people can some people
can't okay you ready
okay okay we're going to do that again
that's kind of nauseating isn't it yeah
ready
okay all right Jesse now what I want you
to do go ahead and turn around
again what I want you to do put your
feet together like you had them hands
down at your sides when I tell you to
begin I'm going to have you lean your
head back like this gently close your
eyes and when you think that 30 seconds
has passed I want you to lean your head
up open your eyes and say stop okay okay
so when I say begin just lean your head
back gently close your eyes and when you
think 30 seconds is passed I want you to
lean your head up open your eyes and say
stop
you understand that
yeah go ahead and lean your head back
close your eyes and
begin okay
so what I want you to do now is how
you're standing just take your right
foot and place it in front of your left
with your right heel touching your left
toe and keep your hands at your sides my
right heel touching my yes ma'am just
just like how I'm doing just like
that go ahead and do that now keep your
hands at your sides and don't move from
that position until I tell you otherwise
do you understand that when I tell you
to begin you're going to take nine Heel
To Toe steps in a straight line right
right here at the end of that nine steps
you're going to take a series of small
steps around your front foot you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps
back in a straight line where you came
from I'll demonstrate it for you you're
standing like this you're going to go
one two three and so on until you get to
nine if this is your front foot you're
going to take a series of small steps
like this around your front foot and
your first step back will be one two
three and so on until you get to nine
you understand that okay I just let you
okay is there any other medical issues
that keep you from like walking
balancing or anything like
that okay um so while you're doing the
test I want you to count your steps out
loud keep your hands at your sides look
down at your feet and don't stop until
you've completed the test do you
understand all those instructions I do
nine correct go ahead and
begin looking her
feet not cting
allow do it matter which way I turn just
as I instructed you I forget which way
you told me to
turn proper
turn it's a reverse
pivot
offline on
five
okay now the next one I want you to put
your feet back together hands at your
sides and I'm going to have you raise
either foot of your choosing when I tell
you to begin I'm going to have you raise
your foot about 6 Ines off the ground
okay I want you to keep your foot
parallel with the ground so your toe
pointed straight out and I want you to
count 1,1 1,002 1003 and so on until I
tell you to stop okay I'll demonstrate
it for you you're standing like this you
can raise either foot I'm going to raise
my right one you're going to go 1,1
1,002 1000003 and so on tell tell you to
stop you understand that while you're
doing the test I want you to keep your
hands at your sides look down at your
raised foot count out loud and keep your
legs nice and straight okay give me one
second okay go ahead and
begin 1001 foot approxim fo off the
ground to point it
up foot down at three this one might be
hard
okay 1001 1002 1003 1004
okay so Jesse what I'm going to do is
I'm going to I'm going to place you
under arrest okay cuz right now I
believe that you're
impaired and you were behind the wheel
of a motor vehicle getting ready to go
get him okay I'm
not well but I believe that you
are so what does that mean sir I I can
get two fingers in there okay so just
leave your hands together like that
Palms facing each other what's that what
this mean I don't understand this means
she is going to go to the jail with me I
mean I don't know the charges I don't I
don't get I don't know why she
fail well based on what I saw is what
why she failed it okay and I I could
include all the reasons why but just
based on my training experience she's
impaired okay is I don't know shit about
it but what the fuck do I
do what do I do all right come over here
for
me this is crazy
I don't know do you have anything on you
that I need to be worried about no okay
I'm just going to check your pocket here
I'm going to use the back of my hand to
check your front
pockets just car
keys
okay goe and have a seat for me do you
want the car keys left
here um well I don't really
know I'm not really sure okay well
they're on you so I'm just going to
leave them with you then okay all right
watch your
leg Marcel here's the
deal um know so here here's the deal
she's going to go to the jail um I'm
going to figure up what I'm all charging
her with right now it's going to be um
physical control of a motor vehicle it's
similar to an OVI um it's not the same
but it's the same kind of charge okay um
do you know if she does drugs or has she
ever done drugs around you I've
never no okay well right now that's
what's going to happen what do you need
to say I I just need to know what I need
to do man her dad's
going okay
fuck Jesse is he allowed to be here I
think that's what he's curious is he
supposed to be here is your dad know
he's
here
well yes and no okay cuz I know there's
been some issues in the past um with him
and at least the one boyfriend that I
know of but um yeah if he's not supposed
to be here he's wanting to know what
he's supposed to do or where he's
supposed to
go well I kind is there anywhere I can
call my dad yeah I mean I can facilitate
that what do you know his number off the
top of your head yeah okay let me get my
phone real quick
okay Marcel we're going to try and get
it figured out real quick
okay is that Mike yeah that's who I'm
getting ready to call that's I just
called cuz I seen your what the hell
hold on here he
is that kid was talking earlier he was
gone hi Mike this is Logan from the
Sheriff's Office how are you okay thank
well so here's here's what's going on um
picked up a guy named Marcel on State
Route 638 he was kind of walking along
the road some people had called in and
expressed concern that they were afraid
he was going to get hit thought it was a
little suspicious but
um I'm okay I have a female
21 um but so I brought him here he said
his his fiance is is Jesse so she was
supposed to be coming to pick him up um
after they got into a fight and when I
pulled in the driveway she was in the
Suburban with the keys in the ignition
eating a bowl of cereal and I believe
that she's under the influence of some
sort of drugs or
alcohol she's uh all they stayed up all
night arguing okay well that's what
that's what he said um she is extremely
tired I know well and I just ran her
through some field sobriety tests and
she did not perform very well um which
being being tired won't really affect
you know walking and
balancing um and there's some other do
not leave and leave him at my house well
that's that's why I was I was actually
getting ready to call you she she wanted
to call you um and Marcel's here
wondering like what he's what he's
supposed to do and I know that supposed
to get off my property okay because I
I've been out here before with one of
her ex-boyfriends and I think you
remember me from that uh so I didn't
know if this was a similar situation
where you know if he's not supposed to
be here you know we need to facilitate
him
leaving yep okay I don't want him at my
place at all hey
done nothing but be bad to
her he's a control he won't even get a
job because he can't stand to be away
from her he wants to have her right
under his thumb where he can watch every
move she makes okay and uh yeah I know
that she's
uh she might smoke some weed I don't
know but uh well she's got some she's
got some white powder residue in her
nose too so oh gosh
I'm not sure um exactly what it is but I
have to inquire a little bit further
about that so why are you taking her in
uh because she was behind the wheel she
said she was getting ready to leave to
go pick him up she had the keys in the
car so it's going to be a physical
control it's similar to an OVI uh but
then when we get to the jail um I don't
know what all I will find out but it she
may have other charges depending on that
but right now it's physical control of
the motor
vehicle oh boy
so um I just like I said I wanted to
touch base with you since you're the
homeowner and I I knew that there's been
some some issues here before with with
her guests so I yeah I told her before I
no more nobody El would stay here
ever
okay well I appreciate you talk to her
or not um if it's going to be something
that's conducive to a a a good outcome I
I don't want to hand you the hand her
the phone and and you just yell at her
no I'm not going to yell at her okay
give me one second you mind
no yeah I don't mind Jesse this is your
dad he's on speaker phone
yeah so let me know as soon as possible
what the bail
is yeah CU this this guy is saying that
I'm impaired I'm not impaired obviously
I don't drink I don't do none of that I
don't know I told him I had back surgery
and um I said some of the things that
you're having me do I may not be able to
do because of my back yeah
and
I I don't know this is
crazy locked up don't want him there uh
well I don't I don't know if the uh
front door is on loged or locked or
whatnot I don't
know do not want my house period Mike
the I don't what was your name Robin
Robin said that she's going to lock the
house up or she'll make sure that it's
locked if you're okay with that yeah I'm
I'm fine with that and my like all right
well I'm going to pass the phone back to
Robin okay okay all
right okay thank you sorry that's okay I
don't know him can you make sure I don't
get attacked as I'm doing this stuff
yeah yeah
absolutely um so Marcel here's the
here's the a deal Mike says he doesn't
want you here um I don't know where
you're going to go I call where you can
go okay I I'll call for my brother to
come pick me up mean there's a park
right here you're more than welcome to
walk to the park and and hang out there
um I don't know where all my act all my
stuff is so I can make sure if it's here
she can maybe bring it to me whenever
she gets out or whatever happens I'm
okay with
that you can come back here
right here in the in her
pocket do you does he want them
left they'll be at the they'll be at the
sheriff station yeah they're just
staying with her if he doesn't want them
left
here just get these well I the front
door is locked so I can't hang in there
but he wants to ask you where his stuff
is Jesse crazy J Jesse um Jesse listen
to me man for real look at me yeah I'm
sorry this shit happened bro and shit's
fucking ridiculous we should not be
fucking fighting like this at fucking 4
in the morning man we got to stop this
shit I didn't mean for this shit to
happen crazy man I to fucking with
handcuffs what the fuck am I supposed to
do look at me just look at me are you
going to ask her about your stuff
ridiculous man what you going to do with
my St you going to stay here until
something obviously yeah or just I guess
just just take it so at this point I
don't even care this is crazy I
shouldn't be in handcuffs I know I
didn't ask for this shit I didn't even
do anything all right what do you want
me to do with your phone so I do have a
question will I go to the um jail and
will someone pick me up or something
like that uh some of that kind of
depends on what all I find out when I'm
talking to you at the jail okay so I
mean we still got a couple other things
to do when we get there but all right
one more thing is this are we done
for we not we're not we're not going to
host the my show I'll just wait my
bad I just
leave what a
cigarette
so I pick him up he says he's been he's
been walking they got into a fight
um
that I I have no
idea
um hold this it has some of my stuff in
it CarX and some of my medicine my
inhaler I mean if if it's your inhaler
you can take it well otherwise cuz I I
can take the purse with me if it's her
belongings all right where's your
inhaler do you want
it or is it with your jacket in this
car uh cuz your sweatshirt's in this car
too okay yeah I'm sorry you're good I
was going to say get the rest of your
stuff out of here and it might be with
that
but he says they've been fighting all
night um huh he does have some stuff
over here in the corner or there was
stuff all of his stuff was out here this
morning and he was moving it that way
and he started walking okay that's when
he started walking so I knew she K him
out
um yeah two of them I pick him up I'm
like hey I I'll just give you a ride he
he's like falling over hold on I want to
talk to one of
them hey Mike yeah uh that Marcel guy
on and uh bottom line I don't want him
up my house okay yeah I'm I'm making him
aware of that right now so he's he's
trying to make some arrangements to get
a couple of his things that he has out
of the purse of your daughter and I I
guess the car that somebody had set him
in but um he's going to be walking in
the park and calling for a
ride yeah I didn't he was supposed to
already be gone when I left the I
started to leave and then came back
because they were having
issues and uh I thought he had already
left cuz all his stuff had disappeared
and he hadn't put it in any of my
vehicles okay yeah I mean he has like a
a sweatshirt and some like little pocket
knives and his inhaler and stuff like
that but um he's he's getting all that
together now and we'll make sure that he
gets off the property before we split
well he had a ton of clothes there well
I mean he's not going to be able to
carry him the the shoelace Express
doesn't have much cargo room so um there
is a chance that he will have to come
back but if he does because you know you
can't hold his things but if he does you
can just ask us to come out and we can
stand by while he gets his stuff and
then he can leave okay not I'm not going
to deny him anything as that CH okay no
and that's what I'm saying I don't think
that you will I'm just saying if he does
and you want us here to just facilitate
that trans transaction that's fine
too yeah all righty all right thank you
uhuh
so B in here I'm like hey just sit tight
I'm going to run up make sure that
you're allowed to be here since he told
me that they were fighting all night
yeah
okay yeah I just told him like he he
said he he's not going to keep any of
your stuff from you he just wants to be
here when you get it so I told him
whenever you come back he can just call
us and we can come out make sure that
there's no issues and you can get your
stuff and he said that's that's
perfectly fine
so um yeah just I would just say you're
good and once you have your stuff you're
fine to to split um but he's he wants to
make sure that you know you're not
supposed to be here unless he says so
okay so totally fine all
righty
okay
26 can you check and see who that mail's
on paper with give them a
19 see what what they want us to
do
um so I go knock on the door door no
answer door flies open on the
Suburban and she's like Hey
sir I'm like what's going on Jesse she's
like I was just getting ready to go pick
Marcel up like slur her words bad
holding a bowl of cereal as she steps
out she's like stumbles into the door
I'm like I don't I don't know though you
should be driving what's going on so he
gets out they're talking so as she's
talking I'm I see white powder all over
her nose I'm like look up for me she's
like I haven't been drinking she looks
up her whole nostrils just coated white
powder and so I ran through the field
Friday she did not well and um I told
her she was being placed under arrest
and you know that's when mean he's not
been an issue okay but it's just kind of
like I don't know he's on parole but he
doesn't remember his parole officer's
number because he went to prison for uh
sex offender registry
violations and he said he's got like
three or four months left he like he
never has to check in he just has to
call the sheriff's office so I doubt
that they want anything done with
him around here yeah his his ID says
lewn what's his last name uh Shazer
Marcel D'Angelo Shazer something like
that any want know if you can ask Jess
if all of his stuff went back in that
house or not cuz they had packed it all
this morning and I seen it as soon as I
got up it was sitting out here I mean if
it's not in here it's probably back in
the house cuz I I picked him up and he
had nothing okay the officer
said so I'm going to run her in I
I'm kind of curious about the powder but
I don't know how I
can without her
cooperation probably not offer a test
she
probably I don't know I haven't asked
yet 4600 can you also check and see if
the Steven subject is on
paper
okay he's on paper with sturgeon I don't
think I have his number I
might I think the only one of their
numbers I have now
oh I
do
last one day last
week but they finally got
it Bo
neigh myb
War I tried Chris and Angie they didn't
answer so I'm just going to run her
in I think
so
yeah Jesse are you on paper no you're
not okay didn't you just get out of
prison not too long ago or did you about
nine months ago you just did all your
time
okay
all right well thanks for coming up I
didn't really know I didn't know what I
had at
first they started talking I was just
like I just send me somebody else cuz I
thought I was going to have more of an
issue when
I put eyes on
her thank you
Robin